next we're going to talk about level of
detail calculation
and we'll talk about those first by
showing an example
so i'm going to bring all my customers
on
by name and then i'm going to bring on
order id and it's going to add all
members
but then i'm going to change order id
from a dimension
to a measure and we have account
distinct
so now we can see each customer and how
many
orders they have so let's sort it and we
can see
one person has 17 orders and we have
1 2 3 4
5 6 7 people have 13
orders and it goes on from there
so what if we wanted to make a
visualization that would show
how many customers had how many orders
and what number of orders was the most
popular
we would need to do a level of detail
calculation
so let's clear the workbook a level of
detail calculation
allows you to build a visualization
and bring on metrics that are at a level
that is different from what's shown on
the visualization
so in order to do this
we need to create a calculated field
that will show us the number of orders
per customer
even though we're not going to have our
visualization be per customer
so let's call this orders
per customer and we'll come here
and we're going to use a level of detail
calculation called fixed
now there are two other level of detail
calculations
and they are called include and exclude
and you can learn more about those
in some of our simply learn classes and
if you have any questions please comment
below and we can answer them
so we're going to do it fixed and you
can choose
dimensions and it computes an
aggregation using only the specified
dimensions
so it will ignore all the other
dimensions and we're going to have it
based on
customer name so we're going to have
fixed customer name
and we're going to call get account
distinct
of order id and make sure you close it
with your curly bracket
and we have no errors and we'll hit ok
and this allows us to see number of
orders per customer
so let's pull it out
first let's make it a dimension and then
pull it out
onto our columns and now we can see
one two three four five six seven eight
up to seventeen so that means we had
some customers just order one and some
customers ordered 17 and we had them
order everything in between
so if we'd never had a customer that had
nine orders
then nine wouldn't appear in this list
now we're going to take
customer id or name
let's do id because it should be unique
and we'll pull it onto rows
and we're going to change it to a
measure and it's going to be
account distinct and so now we can see
how many customers ordered how many
items
so we have our number of orders per
customer
which is at the per customer level even
though this visualization is not at the
per
customer level there's nowhere in this
visualization where we pull on the
customer
item as a dimension so
let's sort it biggest smallest and we
can see
that 134 of our customers ordered five
items
or had five orders and so it just five
is the most popular
seven is the next most popular 17 is the
least popular
one is relatively unpopular which is
interesting to know
and so you can use this to analyze how
many items your customers generally
order
and maybe if they have four
items that they are going to order that
perhaps if you made good suggestions you
could get them to go up to five
and that's an introduction to level of
detail
so let's name this sheet
level of detail lod
orders per customer
perfect now let's make a new sheet
and we are going to do an analysis about
new customers so we'll call this level
of detail
new customer analysis
so this visualization is going to be
about customer acquisition over time
so when we do things over time we grab
our date and pull it up here
and for a line chart or anything over
time
we're going to use these
so that it makes an axis instead of
just change to line
instead of dimensions or something that
is not continuous
and then we're going to take our
customer id
pull it onto rows but let's change it to
[Music]
account distinct customer id and now we
can see our count of customers on every
day
i think day is too low of a level let's
go at month
so now we can see how many customers
made an order during what month let's
take region
and split it out by region
we click on central we can see central
now this is including
all customers but say we only wanted to
include a customer when they're making
their very first
order so we're only going to include
their first order so we need to create a
calculated field
and we want to compare we'll call it new
or existing and we want to compare
their order date per customer
to their first order date the min order
date
nope order date
and we're going to get this error it
says cannot mix
aggregate which is min and non-aggregate
functions
and what it's saying here is that
this order date is at a per row level
since we don't have any aggregation on
it and this order date
is at a per visualization level so it's
only going to split up based on
the visualization and it won't let you
put those two things together
so we're going to use our level of
detail calculation again
and we're going to make this fixed per
customer id
and then we'll do our min order date
so now instead of trying to return
something different based on the
visualization it will always return
the min for each customer id so if the
order date on the visualization
is equal to this order date
if the order date on the visualization
is equal to the first order date for
that customer
then new
else existing
end so when
the order date equals the very first
order date that means that the new
customer making their first order
otherwise it's an existing customer
because it's no longer
their earliest date apply okay
and now we can take our new field which
is new or existing
drag it onto filters and we only want
new
we'll hit apply and we can see that we
have
new customers but less over time
so so now we're going to change this
count distinct
to be a running total and we can see
over time
how our new customers are adding up so
it's taking the prior value and adding
our new customers and then at the end we
get our total customers for each
region and we can now make this a more
the lowest level which is day and you
can see
places where it like levels out so we
can see we have a lot of new customers
and it's increasing but then
here for the region of east
there kind of is a level spot where
we're not getting new orders
and that seems to be the same for each
of them so for february of 2014 why were
we not getting any new orders
and how come the west region is getting
new
customers how come the west region is
getting new customers faster
here while it's leveling out in the red
it looks like the west region leveled
out as well but picked up
sooner and started getting new customers
so this type of analysis will help you
view new customers over time
and it's only possible because we were
able to do a level of detail calculation
here on new or existing that would
compare
this data at only aggregating the data
for the specified dimension
so we were able to grab their minimum
order date here
so those are a couple of ways that level
of detail calculations can be very
helpful
thank you for joining us today for any
questions please visit
www.simplylearn.com or post any
questions below on the video
thank you and have a great day
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here